عماره انتهى الشمال زجاجها وتعرضت لاضرار
لقطه تلخص المشهد في العاصمه كياف بعد
ضربات الروسيه التي تعرضت لها ليلا
رغم عنف القصر في هذا الحي شمالي شرق
العاصمه الاوكرانيه لم يقع ضحى
لان الانذار اطلق سابقا علمنا ان الهزه
نتيجه عن انفجار ذهبت الى الشرفه ورايت
الزجاج المهشم
في اليوم السابقي اعلنت صافرات الانذار عن
سلسلتها هجمات الروسيه على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه تظهر هذه الصوره التي نشرت
سلطات حطام طائره مسيره تحمل عباره سنه
سعيده خطه بالروسيه خلال اليوم الاحد دمر
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني 41
في ذلك الخوف
موسكو اكدت انها استهدفت خلال ليلتين
متتاليتين من الهجوم الجويه
وتحدثت عن قتلها لمئات الجنود الاوكران في
جبهات عده